[Music]
good morning Hank it's Wednesday May
16th you may notice that the puffs level
is a little high there's so much puff on
the side tank
puff puff it reminds me of when I was in
high school and they called me muffin
Hank I don't know if you can see the
beads of sweat dripping down my forehead
but it's been a long day here in New
York City it's hot and I've spent the
day reading the screenplay of the
Looking for Alaska movie or as it's
known in Hollywood famous last words
they're changing the title of the movie
because you know Looking for Alaska
sounds like it's a movie about
mountaineering or something anyway Hank
I think it's a pretty good screenplay
even though it's way different from the
book and let's just keep our fingers
crossed that they make it
Hank even though so far as I can tell we
haven't gotten official permission from
evil baby orphanage creator Brook to
make it into a movie slash novel slash
graphic novel slash we don't know what
yet I think we should move ahead with
the project unfortunately it's hard to
write collaboratively about something
when you're not allowed to communicate
via text so I'm going to propose that we
discuss the evil baby orphanage in
videoblogs but obviously we can't do it
in the Brotherhood 2.0 video blogs so I
propose that we make a series of evil
baby orphanage videos in which we're
reading to each other from our proposed
book proposals is that grammatically
correct I'm gonna go with it and then
eventually we'll create a book propose a
lot of the things that we're reading to
each other that shouldn't be too hard
right I mean we don't need text anymore
text is dead just kidding on this text
so bad Hank I miss it I miss and I miss
it sometimes I'll open up the
instant-message window and I'll make
it's a broken golf club then I'll just
have it sitting there and I'll type into
it but I won't hit enter so I don't
break the rules hey I just told everyone
what your screen name is now obviously
the nerdfighters have to have access to
the evil baby orphanage videos so I'm
going to propose that we also post them
on Brotherhood 2.0 over the weekends if
and when we actually do this okay okay
moving on oh wait before we move on can
I just say one thing
an evil baby orphanage does have to
contain evil babies but babies grow up
and what they grow up into is teenagers
who become kind of maybe evil baby
junior counselors you know they got to
take care of the evil babies they got to
change the evil diapers etc and what
would it be like Hank to be 14 or 15
years old and all of a sudden realized
that there
on this mountaintop school in Canada and
are never allowed to leave campus is
because you are an evil baby from the
past I'm just saying I think it might be
interesting okay really moving on now
Hank in your last video you correctly
pointed out that I was born in the city
of Indianapolis the city I'm moving back
to you incorrectly said that I lived
there until I was three in point of fact
I lived there until I was three weeks
old Hank I know that you have a limited
knowledge of my early years due to the
fact that you weren't alive for them but
don't you remember how we lived in
Michigan and then move to Birmingham and
how you were born in Birmingham and how
then we moved to Florida
geez anyway Hank eventually you won't
have to remember that I left
Indianapolis when I was three weeks old
because all that stuff will be covered
on my Wikipedia page or as you like to
call it we keep edia come on Hank this
isn't Canada say with me Wikipedia it's
not quite there yet but it's getting
there Hank I'll see you tomorrow
PS Hank the Yeti just officially became
a master look at these awesome pictures
I took my gosh I'm like Ansel Adams only
you know drunk forget the video vlog
Hank I'm going into professional
distance photography